joining me now Byron New York Chief
political correspondent for the
Washington examiner Fox News contributor
and Chris Bedford executive editor for
the common sense Society Byron I thought
that line from the White House council's
Office you know as a former White Collar
criminal defense attorney that line
saying he was not in business with his
son
go ahead Byron what is that reassurance
that's why they have a word called
lawyerly that's very lawyerly remember
that Joe Biden has over the years denied
repeatedly that he knew anything about
his son's businesses about the foreign
Shady connections that took place when
Joe Biden was the vice president and
after he was the vice president and
continued perhaps until he became the
actual president the WhatsApp message
you're talking about July 30th 2017
that's the biggest piece of new evidence
that we've seen in quite a long time and
there's it Hunter Biden simply says he's
threatening this Chinese business
associate saying if I don't get what I
want from you right now dad is right
here and he knows a lot of people and
it's going to be really bad for you I
you know I it's the strongest piece of
evidence we have yet that Joe Biden was
aware and was there and if he wasn't if
Hunter Biden was lying if there's some
other Circle circumstance then we need
to know that
now Chris Hunter's attorney Chris Clark
released a statement today and they're
never on camera of course saying any
verifiable words or actions of my client
in the midst of a horrible addiction are
solely his own and have no connection to
anyone in his family Chris he is a
victim they you knew they were going to
play this game it's the drugs that did
it this wasn't real I wasn't at my dad's
house where apparently photos you know
actually show him that he was there
um what do you make of this and it
certainly was connected to his bank
account because just a few weeks after
that message was sent over five million
dollars was transferred from the Chinese
company he was talking to or accounts
associated with it to accounts
associated with Hunter so it absolutely
worked he was in business for this I
mean you see the Department of Justice
now redacting information in the
non-classified document that they were
forced to share with Congress that
showed examples of actual reference
examples of actual voice recordings of
not just Hunter Biden talking to the
president of verism Prisma but also
allegedly Joe Biden himself on two
different occasions talking to the
president president of Breeze about
these actual accounts they had now
Washington Post the New York Times they
finally tackled the story but they
tackled it in a way that's designed to
take it down you've got multiple IRS
agents coming out and saying the doj was
stopping this investigation they
wouldn't let it go forward they were
blocking the U.S attorney everything
they're saying is a lie and here are
multiple examples in both the post and
the New York Times took those some
specific examples and said well we don't
actually know where Joe Biden was
sitting at that moment but that's not
the accusation even though that's a
bombshell the whole thing was the doj is
shielding the president from this and so
is the media well the White House Press
Secretary today
went back to the podium to try to play a
little defense herself watch
you've stated
the president stands by his comment from
the 2020 campaign that he never once
discussed his son's overseas business
dealings with his son and you stood at
that Podium and you reaffirmed that do
you stand by your reaction what I will
say is nothing has changed nothing has
changed and I will leave it there
Byron um they need to realize this you
know that is this enough at this stage I
mean a lot has changed even if you know
we have the reporters like Andrea
Mitchell who said well we can't
authenticate these WhatsApp messages
like I'm pursue the story okay pursue
the story well
yeah well you know white houses can
exist in bubbles uh and certainly as of
Tuesday uh the White House seemed to
think that the whole Hunter Biden thing
was over and closed he pleaded guilty to
two misdemeanors they dropped the Dr uh
the gun thing and everything's fine uh
and you know 48 Hours outcome with
Republicans with this evidence uh that
they have gathered and it is by no means
all of the evidence uh that they have
got so you know the idea that President
Biden could actually believe that he's
over this thing that he's gotten past
this thing I find that actually
believable the White House has not yet
really figured out that another house
can another party controls the House of
Representatives and it's not going to go
away
well this was an amazing week and also
another week when the American Media the
corporate media has utterly embarrassed
itself and the way that they covered
this or didn't cover it or didn't pursue
it it is I mean it's why this is you
know all that's going down they got
their credibility is shot Byron Chris
have a great weekend thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else